your conception of patriarchy as i see  it in the book is that quite a lot of  men are quite nice and they do nice  things for women no that's not my  conception of patriarchy and i don't  require men or advise them to be nice  well you do talk about the guy who's the  tampon king the sanitary towel king of  india right i wouldn't call that nice  okay  brave why is it when uh  men do something for women  it's like oh that's so nice of you and  they don't think of  the the things that it took to do that  and say like like i appreciate it more  and i'm not saying all women do this but  it's like that's nice of you because  you're supposed to be able to do  something for me like why  why is that  it's it's our society it's everything  i'm telling you once you see it you  can't unsee it like everything is just  geared towards women  everything and anytime a man does  something great they minimize it or try  to say a woman did it too